die schuldenlast jetzt gilt über ok ok
[Gelächter]
alles klar dann will ich das sogar mit
video seines thomas besser ist als ich
irgendwann später thomas erst mal let's
go würde ich sagen ja jetzt nicht raus
ja ja ja ich herzlich willkommen mit
dabei ist der gute herr wir fliegen das
alte tower ist man sieht ja auch weil
ich so direkt so einfach raus ich will
den fallschirmsprung genießen das macht
einfach zu befördern oder bin genauso
früh da wie du da bist du willst du dich
treffen ja ziemlich schützen
kommst du dir hoch ging für den part bei
der darbietung waren was denkst du ich
denke dass du stirbst du das nicht hast
schon drauf ich tue und darum müssen wir
denn hier
also du hast ja ein musikvideo gemacht
na das ist ja jetzt gerade raus kommt
und wer hat den fall gemacht hast du das
ist mir egal ich kann
hast du schon gesehen ja ich hab's schon
geht also ich hab schon gesehen ja ich
hab's nicht gesehen ich habe es auch
geschnitten und gefilmt und so glaube
ich dass mein name steht am anfang von
dem video du kannst mir gar nichts
also wer sonne gesehen hat stimme ab das
ist in der bildung beschreibung könnte
das auf jeden fall mal rein
wir haben dann auch an drehtagen geiles
bild gemacht könnte auf einem interview
sehen check das mag ich habe es gesehen
haben jetzt schon samstag oder sonntag
wenn das video schon draußen ist was ja
ich werde den verein ist das eigentlich
viel arbeit das schneiden ja das war
richtig viel arbeit also wegen dir nur
wegen dir du bist mir das hier an muss
ich ja dass ich bleibe dabei auch von
einigen für standard vielen videos
schneiden hinein verzicht auf süßes für
arbeit schon darüber stecken
also safe mindestens ist ja nicht viel
sitzen dann wie das auch immer
eigentlich oder ist eigentlich normal
sind ja ja klar freuen kann sich das gar
nicht vorstellen wie möglich für so paar
sekunden man so lange dran sitzen aber
es lohnt sich auch wenn ich meinen mann
generierte so eine komplett neue welt
also wenn ihr bock habt mal wieder zu
sehen wie das abgeht ich habe auch noch
gestern oder dazu geladen wie ich so ein
bisschen die visual effects erklärt wir
können wir auch reinschauen es auch ganz
interessant das sieht man auch mal wie
du dich baby bilder bei mir ist so ganz
ohne visual effects wieder so aussieht
hh wir haben inzwischen tower ist halt
wirklich niemand habe apropos bahn immer
action haben jetzt bist du ein
rambazamba
jetzt habe ich muss dich das tab
ich wünsche ihnen ein garagen die
parkende auto kämpfen hier die parkende
auto
[Musik]
ich habe mit 84 82 am anfang ganz starke
durch altstadt läuft bei nur 25
der bluechip
a
[Musik]
nun standen zudem skill award stellt
sich was sie schon immer oder ja ich bin
ein richtiger lustig ein komiker wenn du
willst dass ich hatte franzi nein das
wäre okay da comdirect ich konnte dir
über ich gehen die putzerei mini also
sprachen lernen ja schon ein blick
gefällt
ich habe ihn ja ich habe den 50 er
gesteht alter ja da kommt noch eine
bitte aber ich muss mal wieder den fokus
richten
das machen wir den kopf werfen da drücke
ich nämlich am main ist die du das video
passt im gesamten tross löffel sein
fokus richtet ist ja so wahrscheinlich
auf reges videos mit küchengeräten
achso messer gabel messer gabel schere
licht sind kleine standen sind zwar
hastig und ich habe seit drei monaten
nicht mehr selber gespielt also das ist
doch kein kirche macht müsste doch ich
habe und das witzig waren sie
entschuldigend mit ersten drei monate
nicht gespielt hast ihr seht jetzt hier
meine okay dass auch du hast gesagt du
willst da hin wo es nur ja dann hast du
in so fliegen
ich habe danach hat der markierte geht
hin also ich sag dir jetzt genau
vielleicht ja wir haben einen counter ab
wann also ich glaub ab jetzt im
vierzigsten kunststoff so ok ok das top
ich das top ich dir aber wirklich die
ganze zeit im kreis betrieben und musste
auch noch was zu sagen jaja
magna war für das falsche ist eine farce
haha ja kaum also über ich hab's länger
blieb das du diese steht bin besser als
du in folge wusste eigentlich welt
tragen bis zu 22 22 doch recht solo
matches icons mache ich das auch für
marie ab jetzt werde jetzt zuerst stirbt
ist besser wieder andere ok damit dann
werde ich das sogar mein video sagen
dass thomas besser ist als ich okay aber
ich darf auch nicht kämpfen also ich
spiele spielt ebenfalls am start aber
ist nicht so es wird so sein du wirst
genug direkt und ich hätte dich
heldenhaft heldenhaft seit ich dich in
einer hitzeschlacht dann werde ich mich
hochziehen wie ein wahrer bruder dave in
cannes
guck mal hier vor uns in welchen okay
okay lass dir direkt freunden oder von
hinten von den studenten aber nicht zu
hoch halten ich werde gleich sowie gilt
ich kann nichts machen
erzählen sie mir so nein nein ich meine
das okay ja ich auch nicht aber dass du
weißt du was bedeutet das
thomas class action wo bist du action
auf der insel
ja ich gehe auf die insel ja man war das
eigentlich der erste größer wird dreh
für dich ja ich habe früher als sonst
fault gedreht war geil oder schlecht
bestellt ab hier ist nicht eine waffe
ich schließe mich erst jetzt nicht eine
waffe magst du da war ich kann ihr
auffällt ist ja also wirst du sterben
da kommt keiner rein bitte was soll ich
machen einfach mal ein guter kerl sein
letzte runde jetzt entscheidet jetzt
entscheidet wer war's jetzt haye ist
schon entschieden auch die schuldenlast
jetzt kate will ok ok alles klar wieso
gehen raus muss loslassen
weißt du was ich komisch finde ich habe
heute schon so zwei solo matches
gespielt und hatte ich immer 4 5 kisten
die leute bei boss aber besser habe ich
einfach so schlechten team und er okay
jetzt ohne spaß sind die leute bei der
user noch besser weil bei so lust hatte
ich nie so ab und das heißt die
schweizer die immer du zusammen zocken
aber ich selber naja ich will das mal
sagen laser mit golftrainer ein bisschen
golf spielen
ich habe bei mir ich habe hier keine
waffe aber auch bei mir
ist nicht eine bitte fortnight da sind
dass auch das ist das motto du bist also
nicht kommt zu dir auch keine waffe
zudem hatte ich habe jetzt keine waffe
natürlich komme und die wollen mich
nicht finden oder wenn du das jetzt
schafft alle danken ehrenmann wenn du
das ist doch keine waffe sie sind aber
noch welche draußen den wölfen bei leute
sind hier noch mindestens um ein gott
hab ich das war nicht der muss ich jetzt
einfach mal lassen
hätten die leute das was mit diesem
video fielen mehr als 200 leben vielen
dank an den lieben fälle dass du dabei
warst doch gerne hkd auf jeden fall das
video das in der video beschreibung
verlinkt sowie der spotify link und
alles mögliche wir denn sonst kriegen
können wir sonst hatte ich auf jeden
fall gelohnt kommt auch das muss ich ja
an habe ich gemacht ist er deswegen auch
galt ja weißt was cooles geworden finde
ich auch die musik und so ich glaube die
leute wenn das feiern scheint hier sind
das einfach so ein flop die wortwahl
hoffen jetzt einfach mal nicht auf ist
aber nicht das war es von meiner seite
schaut auf jeden fall bei dem standard
skill vorbei gibt dem video nach oben
wenn solche fälle wo ich so richtig was
heimischen abmoderation ist
[Gelächter]
was gut
[Musik]